Back in the old days, they never looked at the
economy as something that they needed to pay
attention to. Like every day we're looking at the
economy. Is it going up? Are we in a recession,
is it going down? In the old days, they didn't
have to do that because it was just like you and
your farm and the weather and like, hopefully
it all went well. But now we are all connected.
Like what happens on the other side of the world
affects you and me. Like we are all connected. And
that's really cool because it means we're all like
organized and we can work together to make better
stuff and everyone prospers. But what it also
means is that your destiny is actually determined
by like a bunch of other people's feelings about
whether things are looking good or bad. And that's
kind of nuts. That's why these mysterious economic
cycles happen is because no one's really in
control. It's just all of us trying to coordinate.
Sometimes it goes well, sometimes it doesn't.